-A movie star right there.
Thanks so much for being here.
-Yeah, I felt a little
challenged
a little bit, like Chevalier,
And I said, "Let me spruce up my
outfit a little bit."
-Yeah, you really did.
By the way, you crushed it
in this movie here.
Look at you in "Chevalier."
Yeah. Yeah.
Now, you actually are
a musician in real life.
-Yes.
-You are.
-I'm from New Orleans.
You know, everybody seems like
they're from -- a musician.
You from New Orleans?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Some New Orleans out there.
-New Orleans shout-out!
-Yeah. Everyone in
New Orleans is a musician?
-Well, pretty much.
-I thought this
was kind of cool.
This is you in the movie,
and this is you as a kid.
-With that bald head.
-Yeah. Come on.
You did it, right?
You did it, bud.
And I was lucky enough to meet
your beautiful mom backstage.
And she's a singer.
-She's a singer,
and my dad's a musician.
He's a saxophonist.
We used to -- You know, we used
to play in the church,
so it was -- We call it --
We have a group chat
called The Jackson 5.
But we're really
the Harrison family.
You know what I mean?
So, it's five of us.
It's my twin sisters.
They play the flute.
I play the keyboard.
My mom sings.
My dad plays the sax.
Yeah, yeah, it was a little --
It's a traveling little
Christian band.
-Was the plan always to be
an actor or be a musician?
-I didn't know I wanted to be
an actor, per se,
but I did know -- I kind of
wanted to be a musician.
Well, I wanted -- Okay,
so, I never told anybody this,
but I did want to be a musician,
but I specifically
wanted to be a pop star.
So -- I know, I know.
And so I auditioned
for "American Idol."
-You did?
-And the first time,
I didn't tell my mom
because I did
the online version,
you know, when you could
submit your little tapes.
I went in my sister's room
and I put on my nice
little outfit, you know,
and I sang a little song,
and they didn't see it.
And I was like, "It's because
of the fact it's on the Internet
and I need to go
to them in person."
So, the next time,
I went in the line
and I waited for a full day,
did the whole thing,
and my mom went with me.
-Wait. I'm sorry.
You auditioned
for "American Idol" twice?
-Twice. And then I did
"The X Factor"
because they wasn't seeing
the vision.
-Wait, wait, wait.
Wait. So you went to --
[ Laughter ]
So then you went
to "X Factor," as well?
-Yeah, because "American Idol,"
I was like,
"Y'all don't understand
what's happening here.
'X Factor' is going to get it."
-Yeah. Did "X Factor" get it?
-Well, they -- No.
[ Laughter ]
Can you believe it?
-Can we talk about "Chevalier"?
-Yeah.
-You're getting rave reviews.
If you want to plug your ears
for a second,
I'll just read
a couple of these.
Deadline says,
"Kelvin Harrison Jr.
is a revelation."
Screen Rant says,
"Kelvin Harrison Jr.
is magnetic,
a marvel in a role that
solidifies him as
a leading man."
Vogue put your movie on its
"10 Biggest Films to Look
For in 2023" list.
And The Root said that you might
be the next Denzel Washington.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-What?!
How does that feel
when you hear that review?
Do you go like, "Wow, Mom,
I might be the next
Denzel Washington"?
-I feel a little giddy,
a little giggly.
-Yeah.
-You know,
it's kind of -- It's surreal,
I guess, in some ways,
but, at the same time,
like, I take it as a compliment
in the sense
that I guess it means
I'm choosing the right roles.
You know, Denzel has always
chosen roles
that where men feel like
they have purpose
and they feel dignified
and they feel dynamic.
You know, I believe that,
as black people specifically,
we're not saints, nor sinners.
We're all of the above,
and our humanity
should feel full.
And those are
the types of projects
I choose and the characters
I like to play,
and if they think that makes me
Denzel-like, then I'll take it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And I know you said
you're a musician,
but do you know
how to play the violin?
Did you know...
-So, violin was
my first instrument.
You saw, you know,
bald-headed me at 7.
That was when I started.
And then Hurricane Katrina
happened,
so the program
that I was in went away.
So I never got back into it,
because I was like,
"It's not that cool
to play violin."
You know what I'm saying?
But -- Because I didn't have no
Joseph Bologne to look towards.
But I basically
had to start up again.
I called my dad
and I was like,
"Yo, they're trying to get me
to, you know, play this violin,"
because I asked
Stephen Williams,
our director -- I was like,
"Can we get a double?"
And he was like,
"No, we'll get a new actor."
[ Laughter ]
I said, "Well --"
-That's a good answer.
"Yeah, we'll get a double.
Yeah, we'll get a new actor.
Bye."
-Right, right.
So I said, "So, let's get
a plan together, Dad."
And, you know,
we did five months,
seven days a week, six hours
a day of just violin training.
And I only had to play
the songs in the movie,
so, you know, it seems more
impressive than it actually is.
-No, no, that's what a movie is.
You crushed it, buddy.
-Thank you.
-You really did do a great job.
-I appreciate it.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Kelvin Harrison Jr.
in "Chevalier."
Take a look.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, Dad,
you watching that, Dad?
Hey, congratulations.
Thanks for coming on.
Kelvin Harrison Jr., everybody.
"Chevalier"
hits theaters Friday.
We'll be right back with
more "Tonight Show."
Stick around. Well done.